our question is for Leah of course so
this season you set some pretty wild
things like can I call you mom and
attack my crack yeah other crazy things
can be expected master this season well
I mean Ian and Brad and Ryan always come
up with the funniest things for me to
say I really don't know what's gonna top
are you man enough to attack my crack I
had a lot of trouble saying that with a
straight face when we were filming but I
would love to put them to the test to
see what they could come up with that's
better than that it's gonna be really
great I'm really nervous so mine is a
cast question and Taylor according to
Instagram you've already been on the lot
so you can try and answer it okay this
show is so hilarious there's no way you
could tape some of these scenes without
breaking out laughing I wanted to know
what was the hardest scene to film
because of that that's such a great
question
Leah I had to wait what was it when I do
like smack a glass out of your hand
remember and then we started laughing so
hard because your glass and I kept
breaking it wasn't supposed to you don't
remember that
no well anyways the two of us laughed a
lot that apparently she doesn't remember
I love watching John do the scenes
because he's so funny yet at the same
time so professional literally
remembering every move he makes his
entire blocking the steps he made the
hand gestures he does and so it's like
I'm laughing because each and every time
he's adding something different while at
the same time still remembering
everything he did prior you I you're
asleep that whole time no it's really
hard to hear you guys from over here to
see you
like it sounds like you're speaking a
different language I would say anything
with niecy Nash in it niecy Nash will
drop me like a bomb I mean she will just
litter you I have I have a little secret
thing with her where my less I did a
movie called Fish Called Wanda and Kevin
Kline won't thank you but Kevin Kline I
think still hates me because I laughed
during some of his best stuff because I
laugh if it's funny it's gonna make me
laugh so I've devised the thing where I
hold something really sharp usually a
toothpick or has been a nail or a
paperclip open and I hold it between my
fingers below the camera and I squeeze
it until I bleed and I will continue to
squeeze it what and I and I sold Niecy I
said look this is what I'm gonna do so
before you start dropping bombs just let
me get ready and of course the first
time she dropped something without
telling me I laughed out loud ruined the
take and now I I come prepared so I know
with these two boys I'm gonna have you
know sharp things I'm gonna be bleeding
a lot
see a lot of band-aids on my fingers
that's that's a good story well it's
true yeah aren't you in the teeth
after I sorry we're waiting for you yeah
next question
oh I'm sorry hi I'm I'm from Los Angeles
and my questions for Leah obviously it
got brought up the whole who would win
in a fight between Rachael Hester thing
but it raises a good point the two
characters are very different people was
curious what it was like for you going
from playing Rachael who's caddie but
ultimately this really sweet nice good
girl - Hester who is kind of psychotic
and crazy and a murderer well I had a
very short gap between finishing Glee
and starting scream queens but I was so
excited to play something different that
I think jumping into it even though it
was such a different character was
pretty seamless and I say that kind of
scared because then that means that
playing a crazy killer was seamless
which it was not but I had so much fun
honestly the neck race was so helpful
for me the the minute I put that on I
didn't feel at all like myself or like
Rachael and the Wardrobe the the the
baggy jeans and the Doc Martens you know
I could just be sitting there with the
neck brace on and it totally contorted
my face and so that really helped
because the transition was pretty quick
but I've been wanting to do something a
little darker and a little crazier so
I'm really glad that I got the
opportunity is it more fun thanks for
that question that was really great is
it more fun no is it more fun um well I
mean so easy to be less than ever let
loose like that yeah for sure it's so
much fun but sometimes it was pretty
easy on Glee would just to be like do
you want to know what I mean what a nice
thing about it I can't do that now hello
hi my name's Lonnie I'm from Atlanta
Georgia and I
is wondering if we're gonna see more of
the Red Devil this season and planned on
it but you never know you're just trying
to confuse us I hope it's working it's
sort of it is well there's a different
theme for the killer right again yeah it
ends up being it's a it's a it's a
different killer this year the look is
different it's sort of a the color is
different color is different that's good
yeah more of an earth tone like ups like
brown like an earth tone different you
see what it's like to work with that
they're great but they're nutters oh
thank you thank you thank you
hi my name is Kelly I'm from an Essex
Junction Vermont the fashion was so
iconic in the show but as a fan I wanted
it to be a little bit more accessible is
there any chance of maybe like a blog or
an app or just tweeting at your girl so
that I can know where to get my fuzzy
jackets and stuff yeah a lot a lot of
you out of hmm on a Chanel or six yeah
that was and then what else would yeah
there's a lot of forever21 I'll be
wearing forever 51 this
but I feel you on the blog idea long
wait to know what advice would you give
to those young boys and girls I would
like to follow your steps I mean like
become actors and actresses and be part
of this amazing project that you're part
of that in this case is a scream queens
you know to becoming entertainer is
different for everybody there's no
specific way you go about it because I'm
sure all of our stories are completely
different but I will say you know in the
Millennial age if you want to act turn
on your camcorder and put something
together seriously when I have ideas
I'll do it I don't have to I don't sit
and say now how can I find a producer to
create this for me I say well you know
what I want so I'm gonna put it together
I'm putting do this movie on my snapchat
do this thing on my YouTube and honestly
the people that are into it they're
gonna watch and they're gonna tune into
what it is you have to say and what
you're into I think the biggest thing
about following your dreams that you
have to always remember is that it's
about you literally following them you
can't just say I want to do this I'm
waiting on this and I wish somebody
would give me a chance you got to give
yourself a chance before somebody else
wants to help out nah stop keep going
keep going now you know why I chose her
to be my protege yeah hi I'm grace from
Maryland
um my question is for everybody and my
question is that if you were to become
anyone from any TV show who would you be
gosh that's so hard I would want to be
Daenerys Targaryen Madison Montgomery
from American Horror Story
I'd be Walter White from Breaking Bad
I'll be I'll be militia from militia Oh
Oh it has to be on TV man Oh a duck's I
guess I'll be care Washington and
scandal I'd be Tina and Bob's Burgers
I'd be nico robin from one piece
John would you John do you ever do it
careful wanna be I don't I was yeah I
always wanted to be Fonzie where I grew
up yeah yeah Taylor what about you do
you have your legendary honestly remain
gonna show with you is a dream act I
want you in the time I was a child
loving you thinking we all love you
we're trying to play it cool but you're
the man you just realized he was on our
show I finally had the nerve all right
I'm so happy you guys are here today and
gracing us with your presence
my name is Kamaria and I'm from San
Diego California hi I was just told that
I was gonna be the last question my
question is for Ian um when it comes to
Chanel number one where did your
inspiration come from as to creating a
character so cold and you know um strong
well then this is you know this is my
throne and nobody else is gonna take it
and I love sorry I love you know emma
has um you played it so well oh I was
screaming at my television
I mean Eman particularly but all these
actors in general like when you when
you're able to put give a script to
these people they they give you a lot of
there aren't a lot of actors who can say
lines exactly the way you hear them in
your head sometimes that doesn't work
with this cast it's almost to a person
they can just get inside what you were
thinking I don't know how that works
shanell was we we needed a mean girl and
we needed the meanest mean girl you
could possibly have she knows sort of
all it and no filter and that was it was
just really exciting and then from word
one Emma just like I mean just like
constant grand slams like knocking them
out of the park and it's not easy we
give everybody
oh just mouthfuls and sometimes weird
things to say and they're just really to
a person just really good we're so
unfortunate it's so fortunate it's so
it's so
atypical to I don't know to ever get
this chance to sort of just like write
words and it ends up on television I'm
so so fortunate but but even extra
fortunate to then work with the caliber
of talent on this stage it's it's really
we love you so much thank you we do cute
but also my collaborators you know Brad
who I wish was here is who's directing
the the first episode of season 2 is
just a is like a brother to me is great
and and as is Ryan was just a genius the
most like i popping he's successful like
television producer in the history of TV
so i I'm a very very lucky person very
lucky
you